luke and becca here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today we are
facing a new
sort of challenge we just got done
spending six
weeks filming in alaska and uh yeah
we've had a few surprises coming home
and i'm a little terrified to show my
wife what's in the car
oh no oh that's so bad it's moldy
oh look at that it smells terrible okay
oh look at that
yo you haven't seen the bad part that's
not so bad come here come here
[Music]
look at that that is a black interior
oh it smells terrible so we've got six
weeks of mold growing like this thick
on the upholstery of our car and it's
raining again
and i gotta see if we can clean it off
well it's a beautiful day to try to
salvage my moldy kia i've bought ozone
generators pressure washers steam
cleaners brushes chemicals i even got my
ppe here
and we're gonna see if the outdoor boys
youtube channel can detail a car
but first let's see if it'll start up
oh it's so slimy
ah
oh
well first things first i better empty
the car and i'm really excited to see
what kind of crazy crap we've got in
there because i'm not 100
sure
oh hey oh i was thirsty
ah
all right got carp bait fishing leads
hand warmers
i think i might have found the problem
this bottled water has been leaking in
the car
and that's probably what caused all the
moisture and the mold problem
yeah it's wet right here from that
leaking bottle of water
oh i found this sweet and sour packet it
looks like the end's been chewed off
what if there's a mouse in here
well that looks pretty gross
paddle board leash now that's a gauge
for measuring crabs
gopro attachment tent poles with an
allen wrench key
a bottle of stage blood a dremel
attachment
nerf gun ah a minnow trap
assorted carp baits a squirrel tail
carp fishing unhooking mat
that is gross tin can opener oh look at
this
see that that's been chewed up by a
mouse the mice around here will chew up
toilet paper use it to make a nest
there's a mouse nest somewhere
now that i've got everything out of the
car i have a pretty good theory about
what happened
the leaking water bottle provided the
moisture and parking the car in the
sunlight for six weeks provided the time
and the heat
and it turned the car into a greenhouse
but that was not enough to make mold
the mold also needed something organic
so all the places where the kids had
dropped food
or there were stains in the upholstery
that's where the mold went crazy
places that were pretty clean not a lot
of mold formed
you can see down here where the kids car
seats are and all the goldfish crackers
ended up
that's crazy but up here where the kids
never touch
that's clean so i think if i had a brand
new car or if i had kept my car a lot
cleaner
the water bottle wouldn't have caused
near as much problems all right time to
survey the damage
oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right step one i'm gonna use the
shop vac to suck out loose material dirt
and any mold spores i can
there was a mouse in the car this is the
nest is all the shredded up toilet paper
he built a nest here in the right rear
bumper uh the question is
is he still in the car or is he dead or
is he escaped or what so i'm gonna shove
the shop back way up in there and see
what happens
well i got the whole mouse nest out but
no sign of the mouse yet so
we'll see what happens
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
bye
all right took half a day but we got all
the vacuuming done now we're gonna spray
the whole car down with mold control
which is supposed to eliminate the odor
kill the mold and prevent it from
regrowing so
we'll see how that does
look how much better that looks already
oh
wow
as soon as the mold killer dries i'm
going to start scrubbing the upholstery
all right got the scrub brush drill
attachment here we're going to use that
to scrub the upholstery
and the rugs and the carpet
wow
[Music]
while i was pressure washing the mats
the mold spray was doing its magic and
check it out
it's done pretty good job look at that
that's a pretty huge change for just
vacuuming and spraying with mold killer
man it smells a load better in here too
but we're not done i'm really gonna try
to get these seats
oh jacob come on out all right we got
this mcculloch pro-grade steamer here
and uh we're gonna see what this does to
the mold
[Music]
oh my goodness look at that
oh wow smells world's better too
come here come here you got to see what
the steam cleaner is doing this thing's
awesome
check this out check it out look at that
wow
look at that i just did that little seat
it took like two seconds
look at the door oh nice i mean forget
the mold when was the last time it was
ever this clean
not since tommy was born
just go and wipe it down
and look at that it really hasn't looked
that good since three kids so
i know a lot of little boots have kicked
the back of that seat
oh a lot of boots a lot of goldfish
crackers and ice cream cones
i'm not afraid anymore it kills the
germs it kills them all
i was concerned there were doubts
i'm using this lightning fast spot
remover
and uh the drill brush and that's
working really good
i think it's gonna actually work guys
i'm i'm getting jazzed
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
now they got the back seats all steam
cleaned gonna put this fan on it
let it dry out now i'm gonna move on to
the front seats
[Applause]
[Music]
so
all right folks day two
get back to work
[Music]
ah that's not good the vacuum just
sucked up my button
give that back
it's all good
so
[Music]
a little confession here i have never
done much auto detailing and this is
hands down
the biggest project i've ever tackled so
i watched a bunch of youtube videos
from the detail geek which is a youtube
channel dedicated
to auto detailing and hats off to the
guy
all of his tips and his equipment
recommendations were really solid and i
couldn't have done it without it
so i'm going to put a link to his
youtube channel in the video description
but that being said we're done cleaning
the inside of the car
and now we need to spray it down with
some uv protector and i'm going to use
this 303
uv protector which is kind of like armor
all and we're going to put the
the finishing shine on the interior
so
so
oh my goodness that is that looks
seriously brand new
yeah it looks so brand new all right
we've cleaned the inner vessel
now it's time to wash this car see if we
can't get the outside looking half
decent
all right nate you want to use the power
washer see if you can knock all those
leaves off
hey
[Applause]
well there we go not too shabby huh i've
had this car for about eight years now
and i think this is the first time
i've ever washed it but looking good
well we've done a pretty bang-up job
getting rid of the mold and we've
cleaned every exposed surface that we
can
but there could be mold lurking in the
hvac system and little nooks and
crannies
and in the foam of the seats and there's
also that mouse that's unaccounted for
and we want
to get rid of everything and really
sanitize this car
which will also help with smells and
we're going to do that with
an ozone generator and this is going to
pump the car
full of ozone which is a toxic gas the
thing that makes ozone different than
other poisons is that it breaks down
within about
45 minutes of being exposed to air and
then it just becomes
harmless oxygen so what we're going to
do is fill this car
as full of ozone as we can and let it
marinate for several hours
and then we're going to air it out and
we should be done
crank that thing up to high and let it
go for 10 hours
you can already smell the ozone it
smells like a burning motor
they use ozone generators to sanitize
grain silos they kill all the funguses
and pests and stuff so
hopefully it'll work for our car
all right guys we're done come check out
the final result
[Music]
well the car is all done it's cleaned
inside and out and sanitized i think we
need to take the family out for a spin
what do you think
yeah it smells brand new and looks brand
new yeah it does
this is nice it's like it's brand new
again isn't it yeah
it looks like it's a blue smells good
all right who wants ice cream
you did an awesome job and i'm very
impressed
oh well you get some ice cream dude
well it took two days and a lot of
manpower to get this car clean but we
did it you guys like it
yeah if you want to see more videos from
the outdoor boys
youtube channel check out our many
camping and survival and blacksmithing
videos don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching